die
ich will dass sie nicht blicken
münchen team süd ist in der bayerischen
landeshauptstadt angekommen die stadt
ist bei touristen beliebt jedes jahr
kommen weit über zwei millionen
ausländische gäste nach münchen die
meisten kennen das bayerische bier oder
den traditionellen tanz den
schuhplattler und viele touristen kaufen
trachtenmode
aber münchen hat viel mehr zu bieten zum
beispiel trendsportarten im englischen
garten surfen wassersportler auf der
eisbachwelle
mit wasser hat auch die aufgabe zu tun
ihr nehmt an einem wakeboard kurs teil
haltet euch eine runde auf dem brett
jeder aus dem team kann heute ein ticket
gewinnen wir müssen einmal ganze wunder
lachen
eine runde auf einem wakeboard sieht
einfach aus oder
alex ist der wakeboard lehrer er erklärt
den anfängern die wichtigsten regeln
jonas ist als erster an der reihe er
hatte noch nie ein wakeboard an seinen
füßen aber er kann snowboardfahren
vielleicht hilft das ja
der start klappt schon mal
aber in der ersten kurve ist bereits
schluss
klar wakeboard profis bewegen sich viel
eleganter auf den wassern jetzt ist
christina dran ob sie länger auf dem
brett bleibt
es will einfach nicht klappen
auch massa landet sofort ins wasser
habe mir das mal raus hat dann macht
richtig spaß
ja natürlich ich kann nichts passieren
und was macht viel spaß daran wenn man
den staat mal hat dann die kurven fahren
und auf dem wasser bogen fahren andere
staats zu üben
nasser probiert es weiter für ihn ist es
eine besondere herausforderung weil er
nicht gut schwimmen kann aber
viel schlimmer ist die kälte
wieder nichts
erreicht es er gibt auf
ja das war doch keine wichtigkeit und
ich kann mich nicht gut weg in vielfach
nur noch jonas und christina können ein
ticket gewinnen
aber auch christina kann nicht mehr
ich muss es schaffen ein bisschen normal
gefahren dann habe ich die verantwortung
für team süd hängt nun alles von jonas
ab
hey nicht übermütig werden
tatsächlich jonas schaffte es als
einziger bis ins ziel
leider hat nur einer die runde geschafft
der jonas glückwunsch an kristina
jonas und nasser haben zwar nur ein
ticket geholt aber sie bleiben in
führung es steht 2 0 für team süd
das ist der hammer ich hatte einen sehr
schönen tag auf dem wasser haben ein
wunder geschafft
am anfang nicht aber dann die kurve
verstanden und dann hat es geklappt
glückwunsch aber schon in der nächsten
folge kann team nord aufholen
nicht blicken